amid all of our national turmoil at the
height of an election year you know we
can always count on the mainstream media
to focus on the important issues ask
the important questions like questions
about
cue anon during the pandemic
uh the q anon movement has been appears
to be gaining a lot of followers
can you talk about what you think about
that and what you have to say
to people who are following this
movement right now
that's what really is on people's minds
you know the
the nation is on fire cities burning
people getting attacked
statues coming down police departments
getting abolished
and you know what we want to hear about
is an internet meme yeah that's that's
that's it thank you great job media an
internet meme that that you in many ways
uh have contrived trump
brushes it off well i don't know much
about the movement other than i
understand they like me very much
[Music]
which i appreciate but i don't know much
about the movement
i have heard that it is gaining in
popularity and from what i hear it's
these are people that
when they watch the streets of portland
when they watch what happened in new
york city in just the last six or seven
months but this was starting
even four years ago when i came here
almost four years can you believe it
uh these are people that don't like
seeing
what's going on in places like portland
and places like
chicago and new york and other cities
great answer his answer is basically
yeah my guys are good your guys are bad
yeah you you people are destroying the
country and if you vote for me we're
going to fix the country
very simple answer the reporter won't
let it go
it is this belief that you are secretly
saving the world from this satanic
cult of pedophiles and cannibals does
that sound like something
you are behind does that sound like
anything you've heard
like you know i don't know like the
democrats booing god at their national
convention
number of years ago or flying around
with pedophiles and airplanes to
caribbean islands
or literally eating human brains on cnn
which is what former cnn contributor
rizza aslan did i don't know
starting to sound not all that
outlandish to me
uh we'll put the q thing whatever that's
so that's completely secondary that's a
distraction
from what is really going on in the
country we will get to trump's
excellent answer i'm michael knowles
this is the michael knowles show
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday from no one that's his
name
according to liberals trump wasn't their
president for four years
so really he should be able to run for
two more terms i totally agree
and stacey abrams should never be able
to run again because she's already
served in so many
positions right she's governor of
georgia she's now the running mate
for joe biden i mean she's had a really
long and storied
career in politics also got to thank our
friends over at ancestrydna
as people are tearing down history all
around us maybe you can take a look into
your own family history
researching your family history is is
tremendous for your entire family you
know my grandfather introduced me to
this
introduced me to ancestry years ago
before the daily wire existed
and i've just loved it i mean it's such
a great hobby
the stories you learn about your shared
past can bring your family closer
together
ancestry dna doesn't just tell you which
countries you're from
also it can pinpoint the specific
regions within them giving you
insightful geographic detail about your
history
we talk on the show about how important
narrative is well learn your own
narrative you know learn the narrative
of your family
it's really it's a tremendous thing a
lot of people don't really do it anymore
but but it's wonderful both unmapping
your family tree and
the the ancestry dna test delivers a
truly unique
interactive experience it is easy to
start making discoveries with ancestry
grab an ancestry dna kit
today start exploring your family
history
head on over to my url at ancestry.com
slash knowles k-w-l-e-s
by the way if you do that some of my
listeners have done it and
added me on ancestry and it turns out
we're like distant cousins and things
like that that's it's very fun to do
ancestry dna kit a start your free trial
that's ancestry.com
knowles maybe i'm your cousin
so this the q anon thing again i mean i
think i thought trump gave a good answer
which is
yeah i don't really know that much about
this thing i vaguely heard about it
mostly just from left-wing media trying
to
turn it into some sort of phenomenon and
some kind of boogeyman
but uh yeah i'm not i'm not that
concerned we've got other things to
worry about
and then the the reporter says yeah but
it's a it
they say that there are satanists and
pedophiles and
cannibals running around and i say right
that's just on cnn where
where are they hiding is what i want i
want to know the ones that are under the
cover
so she pushes it and pushes it and
pushes it people are criticizing trump's
answer i thought he gave
an excellent answer well i haven't i
haven't heard that but is that supposed
to be a bad thing or a good thing
i mean you know if uh if i can help save
the world from
problems i'm willing to do it i'm
willing to put myself out there
and we are actually we're saving the
world from a
radical left philosophy
that will destroy this country and when
this country
is gone the rest of the world would
follow
beautiful point see what a number of
conservatives have wanted trump to do
and they're
venting their frustration about trump's
answers they want trump to say oh it's
terrible i hate everyone
everyone who has any kind of kooky view
i hate them they're terrible there are
no good people i don't want their
support
the whole point of the reporter's
question about this
non-traversing is to make trump
supporters look like kooks
that's the whole point they've done this
for decades it's like a standard
democrat playbook
and trump is not going to play into it
he jokes he makes a couple jokes about
it right he says oh
you're telling me i'm saving the world
from satanic
pedophile cannibals that's it sounds
pretty good is that
should i not be doing that should i be
supporting the satanic
and then he says look there forget about
the satanists or whatever
you're saying that i'm saving the world
from problems uh that's what i'm trying
to do that's what we're trying to do in
politics and uh
and you guys are trying to destroy the
country and i'm trying to fix the
country
and i i like it when people support me
in that mission
to fix up the country a little bit on
the broader point of the q anon
thing i really i don't even care to
address that
i have a message for the democrats which
is that people who spent the last
four years pretending that donald trump
is a secret kgb spy
do not get to lecture conservatives
about conspiracy theories
okay you don't people who think
that there is a grand conspiracy
to close mailboxes in democratic
districts to steal an election
particularly people who belong to a
party that has tried to steal an
election and overturn an election
for the past four years don't get to
lecture conservatives about conspiracy
theories
i i don't want to hear that phrase again
out of the mouth of a democrat
or out of a mouth of a of a leftist
activist or
most of all out of the mouth of the
mainstream media i don't want to hear it
you've lost that privilege russia gate
was the end of that
especially now that we see that there
was a conspiracy with regard to
russiagate but it wasn't from the trump
campaign it was from the obama
administration
and the press ignored it and covered it
up for years we're finally seeing this
come out now
with with charges being brought against
various
fbi and doj officials somebody tells me
there's a lot more to come not that the
mainstream media will ever look into it
and in fact there was an episode
yesterday
totally separate from what you would
call practical politics
party politics that that illustrates
just how far the mainstream media have
fallen
this involves a former navy seal this
guy robert j o'neal
guy who killed osama bin laden he
tweeted out a picture of himself
on an airplane sitting up there without
a mask on
and he takes the picture and he says i'm
not a
wuss i'll translate he used a more
colorful word
i'm not a wuss my man love that looking
great
standing up against this stupid leftist
political culture we now have
that makes us muzzle ourselves on
airplanes so
he posts that picture and immediately a
new york times editor
dan solstein tweets out
i don't know this guy but counterpoint
you might just be
because you're not willing to sacrifice
and be a little
uncomfortable for your fellow humans
including that marine behind you
now obviously uh obviously this navy
seal does know a thing or two about
sacrifice
and being made a little uncomfortable
for the good of his countrymen
knows a whole lot more about it than dan
saltstein
whose greatest sacrifice for america is
writing for the new york times
which is which in fact sacrifices
america
sacrifices our integrity journalistic
integrity
the issue here isn't the tweet i don't
care about this little twitter spat
between
between o'neill and solstein it's the
incompetence
it's the laziness if if i had done that
if i had not known who this guy would
that'd be one thing
if your average layman in the street had
not known who robert
that would be one thing an editor of the
new york times
is supposed to know how to investigate
things
an editor of the new york times should
at least know to make a google search
before you start lobbying charges like
that
but they don't they don't you know the
new york times was always left-wing
and and often dishonest but
they weren't incompetent they weren't
lazy
now we have this generation of of new
york times
you know generally journalists editors
writers
who who are just lazy and incompetent
don't know the basics
of their job so if a new york time
editor can't even get this question
right
how are you supposed to trust his
reporting on anything else drew clavin
always
points this out where you're reading the
new york times and you don't know about
any of the stories so you're just kind
of reading to get filled and
then you get to one story that you do
know about who knows say it's the new
york yankees i don't know or it's some
area of manufacturing maybe you know
something about it and you read it and
you think gosh
they got this totally wrong i know that
this is wrong because i
i know about this topic but then you go
right along and you believe all the
other stories that you don't know
anything about
the longest lasting trump legacy i think
will be
the complete collapse of the credibility
of the mainstream media
sometimes it's laziness sometimes it's
incompetence other times it's just
dishonesty like when cnn defends
bill clinton which we'll get to in one
second first i've got to thank our
friends over at rad power bikes
you know electric bikes are like regular
bikes but they're a lot more fun and
they require way less effort
whether you want a new way to get around
town maybe you want to go out in nature
you've got to try rad
power bikes this is a cross between a
traditional bike and a moped
but nice thing here it doesn't require a
special driver's license like a moped
would
you can go up to 20 miles per hour
without pedaling you can get out and
about without getting sweaty
unlike other e-bikes they're actually
affordable plus
to show appreciation for those that
serve us rad power bikes is offering 100
off all ebike purchases for active and x
military first responders
teachers and students dedicated wow even
students that's pretty good i don't know
how i don't have a student service but
look rad powerbox is very generous so
take advantage of this right now
dedicated us-based customer support
seven days per week to answer any
questions
or concerns makes the perfect gift for
someone who loves being active
and outdoors uh they're they're offering
flexible financing for as low as zero
percent apr
right now limited time offer get a free
accessory with purchase of a bike
that is a free gift of up to one hundred
dollars in value
and free shipping to the lower 48 states
to get this special offer text the word
knowles can wles to 64 000. that is
knowles know wlas
to sixty four thousand what is it tex
knowles
to sixty four thousand so cnn even after
bill clinton's
generally panned uh convention
appearance
decides to defend him because to cnn's
credit they bring up this question
why is it that in the metoo era when
everybody is getting taken down for even
looking crosswise at a woman 20 years
ago or even
not looking crosswise but they're just
kind of crazy allegations that come up
in the case of brett kavanaugh for
instance
how is it that bill clinton has managed
to survive
in that culture and they've got
a one-word answer maybe a two-word
answer
second chances how has he survived
all of these waves of cancellation when
he has been one of the biggest violators
of these
rules at all these years i mean we we
talked about this
character we talked about we talked
about the use of
listen there it is the one word answer
is redemption the two word answer is
second chances
and democrats actually believe in
neither of them right
i'm kind of i'm more exercised by the
second chances thing though because
in cancel culture you don't get a second
chance i understand
maybe you don't want to give someone a
third chance or a fourth chance but you
don't get a second chance at all
unless you're a democrat unless you're a
leftist
left believes in redemption how
show me how the left believes in
redemption
they don't they'll smack down anybody
who comes in their way
whether it's a comedian whether it's
look ellen degeneres
took a photo with george w bush they're
out for her head
right kevin hart made a an
unpopular comment or something they go
after a joke he he told 10 years ago a
joke
that virtually every other stand-up
comedian in history has made as well
i don't think they're i don't think they
believe in redemption
except for their privileged feud this is
not some sort of nice
principle whereby we say we're gonna
have grace we're gonna have forgiveness
they don't believe in any of that stuff
it's it's purely cynical they'll cover
for their guys
and they'll attack your guys even if
there's no
evidence whatsoever that they did
anything wrong again like the case of
brett kavanaugh
cnn van jones they go on
you were talking about bill clinton's
character and what i
admire about bill clinton is that he has
acknowledged his wrongdoing
he's apologized he's tried to rebuild
his family
and i think apologies don't come as
often or as easily
from the present white house even when
they should so i don't i don't think we
can
i don't think we have to say everything
bill clinton has done is great
but i do think that when he has made
mistakes he's acknowledged them and i
admire him for that
was van jones alive in the 1990s does
was van jones does he is he remembering
the same bill clinton i'm remembering mr
clinton
any response to van jones's point that
you take responsibility for the things
you've done
i want you to listen to me i'm going to
say this again
i did not have sexual relations with
that woman
miss lewinsky i never told anybody to
lie
not a single time never these
allegations are
false and i need to go back to work for
the american people
thank you need to go back to the you can
even see
at the end of that clip if you're
watching it he has a little smirk at the
end i can't believe they believe that
that's so fun man i'm a good actor i
should have been in hollywood
um i should have hung out with harvey
weinstein
um yeah bill clinton totally not
acknowledging
what i did and then later on he he got
caught
and so utterly shamelessly he goes out
on television
and says okay maybe well a little a
little bit but
and even then i believe the exact
wording was
well what i said was not technically
well what i said was technically true
i misled it's like well you lied you
lied and you're still
you're even when you are forced to
acknowledge it do not acknowledge it but
but
the democrats believe in redemption
right as long as you acknowledge what
you've done he's still doing it
like you know i i grew up a town over
from
from chappaqua where uh where bill
clinton grew up and one side of me was
aoc
in yorktown then on the other side of me
was uh was bill clinton
and rumors swirled let's just uh let's
put it that way i don't want to report
any rumors but something tells me that
guy
did not quite reform himself and by the
way bill clinton was like the good old
days
the the i would take bill clinton's
democratic party any day
over the democratic party of these
current crop
of of radicals so right now during the
dnc
there was the dnc lgbtq caucus meeting
and a member of this caucus jay mai
i don't know who that is described
what their aims are you know democrats
in recent days have said we're not about
abolishing the police we're not about
well j my in this open democratic caucus
meeting says that is
exactly what we are for we're talking
about abolishing the police we're
talking about abolishing ice we're
talking about abolishing prisons
there it is there it is and you remember
what aoc said when when
the democrats continued to hear the
younger crops say we're abolishing the
police we're abolishing ice we're
abolishing prisons
they said well abolishing the police
doesn't really mean abolishing the
police and then aoc came out with a
press statement god bless her i mean she
at least she was honest about it she
goes
no abolishing the police means
abolishing the police doesn't mean
removing a little bit of funding or
moving some funding around it means
actually abolishing getting rid of the
police
so that's the that's the democratic
party it's so funny
what they've been trying to do is hide
some of these sessions but
part of the the issue with them pushing
this continued lockdown needlessly
pushing this continued lockdown
is these sessions are all on video and
it would seem that we've got republican
operatives in every single one of them
and so the video keeps leaking and then
what happens when the video leaks
well the biden campaign has to distance
itself right because the biden campaign
is pretending
that this is a moderate democrat
campaign for a moderate democrat party
even though we all know that the minute
joe gets into office if he's even aware
that he gets into office you're going to
have this crop of radicals
running the country so the biden
campaign says i bet the police
the campaign has been very clear when it
comes to defunding the police they do
not support defunding the police and i
don't know how many times we have to say
this
on this network or others but that is
the case now at other times
the biden campaign has seemed very open
to defunding the police but
neither here nor there they're denying
it now how about linda sarsour we were
talking about linda sarsour a little bit
yesterday i believe linda sarsour is
this islamist radical leftist
activist and she was she's so radical
that she
was kicked out of the women's march but
she was permitted
to speak at the democratic national
convention
so the biden campaign has to has to do a
little damage control here
joe biden has been a strong supporter of
israel and a vehement opponent of
anti-semitism his entire life and he
obviously condemns
sarsour's views and opposes the boycott
divest sanction movement
as does the democratic platform says
campaign spokesman andrew bates
she has no no role in the biden campaign
whatsoever well that's strange if the
whole democratic
platform and dem i mean i suppose who
writes the platform is the party
if the party so despises linda sarsour
why did they give her a slot to speak at
the convention doesn't make a lot of
sense
and frankly the only reason that the
biden campaign even responded to this is
because trump
tweeted about it this is the big problem
here for
the biden campaign the biden
campaign is behind the ball they're
following their party they're trying to
catch up to their party the party is
leading
and the party is now radical so the
the biden campaign can come out and say
no no we uh we don't really want to
defund the police no no we don't
really hate the jews no no we don't we
don't really support linda sorcerer
but the fact that they have to keep
playing catch up like this shows
they're not the ones in charge so who
care who cares what they say or what
they think
the trump campaign on the other hand is
going on offense and this was a move
yesterday again
somewhat controversial among
conservatives mostly among libertarians
but
but some conservatives too got a little
a little frightened by this
the the trump well first through trump's
twitter but then through the trump
administration and kaylee mcinanny they
came out and said yeah we don't like
goodyear anymore goodyear tires
we went through their their slideshow
yesterday on this show
but goodyear showed seem to have this
policy which is that it's okay
to express views in support of blm or
the lgbtq
movement but you can't support
any sort of expression for blue lives
matter or all lives matter or wearing a
hat that says
make america great again or anything
like that so you can support left-wing
things but you can't support
right-wing things trump said don't buy
goodyear the left is going to play this
game we'll play it too
get stop having good year right stop
supporting goodyear
and kaylee mcinanny was asked about this
at a press briefing
i thought she gave a great answer here's
the question
today the president encouraged americans
not to buy
goodyear tires suggesting that they had
a ban on maga hats but it appears
that their policy is just a ban on
political speech it's pretty common for
most companies
so why is the president retaliating
against a private company for their
dress code and potentially jeopardizing
american jobs
okay i want to pause here for one second
because this reporter
typifies the dishonesty of leftism for a
hundred years
what the slideshow showed was you yes
blm yes lgbtq
no maga no blue lives matter no all
lives matter
and she says and at the very end of the
unacceptable line they said
no political speech so what the left is
saying is
conservative speech that i don't like
blue lives matter all lives matter
make america great again support the
president that
is political and therefore
unacceptable whereas black lives matter
and lgbtq
that's not political that is just the
orthodox dogma of the state you can't
you can't
possibly question transgenderism
that's our established church you can't
that's not political
blm run by three avowed marxists
wants to destroy the nuclear family
according to the about us page on their
website
that's not political what the left has
done here
ironically is they have
made everything political except for
politics
right everything is political now you go
out you buy a cup of coffee it's
political
anything you wear anything you say
anywhere you go the kind of car you
drive what
everything has become political now the
mask is everything is political
except for politics and this has been
what the democratic party has pushed for
since woodrow wilson they basically want
to take all the important questions
out of the realm of politics give it to
bureaucrats give it to administrators so
that we can't debate about it anymore
and the government can just do whatever
they want but they'll
they'll at the same time politicize
everything so we're arguing about
absolute diversions gets to this q anon
question too
we're arguing about internet memes as
though this is really important
meanwhile we're told that substantive
questions like the marxist organization
blm that's outside the realm of politics
whether a man can become a woman lgbtq
you know whatever the alphabet continues
to grow by the day
that is outside the realm of politics
we're not allowed to have opinions about
that anymore i thought kaylee macinnani
handled the question in a in an
excellent
manner goodyear needs to come out and
clarify
their policy there was an image they
failed to clear
yes i did see their statements which
still still fared failed to clarify
their policy what happened is there was
an image that was put out
that showed that certain speech was
acceptable black lives matter
insignia for instance but what was not
allowed was blue lives matter what was
not allowed was maga hats
what was clearly targeted was a certain
ideology they have not denied that that
image
was presented at one of their facilities
and they need to come out racial
equality racial justice that is okay but
not political speech that's pretty
standard across the board right now
that's not that unusual
did the president even reach out to
goodyear before they came out and said
equity issues
there it is it's it's just racial
justice it's just
sexual equality that's not political
what do do these people know what the
word politics means politics means
public things the things we all do
together how we all live together in the
city and the paulus
right greek word that's that's politics
they say no that's not politics
politics is like your internet memes and
like the maga hats and the things i
don't like
so that you can't do politics it's like
they always say this
in schools you can't talk about religion
you can talk about how a man is really a
woman
and you can talk about that which is
called gnostic dualism by the way that's
a religious concept
but you can't talk about christianity
you're not you can't you can't do that
you can talk about equality and justice
and the 1619 project in blm
but you can't talk about politics even
though the author of blm says this is
not
a history that's being taught it's
activism
but they say no no that's not it's not
the things i like are not politics and
therefore we
we should just all accept it and the
things i do not like
that is politics and we've got to get it
out of we what we need
so much of the trump movement has been
forget about the judges forget even
about
breaking down the media it's been about
expanding the realm of politics
in an authentic way in in a proper way
because we had been told for decades
look you're not allowed to have an
opinion about outsourcing you're not
allowed to have an opinion about
immigration you're not allowed to have
an opinion about
the loss of american manufacturing
you're not allowed to have an opinion
about our role in transnational
institutions you're barely allowed to
have an opinion about international
interventions and foreign wars
you're just not allowed that is separate
that's being run by the brilliant people
at the state department or in the
bureaucracy elsewhere
and that's not in the realm of politics
and what trump came in and says nah
i think it is i think we're going to rip
up trade deals we're going to build a
wall on the border
and you stupid bureaucrats aren't going
to have a damn thing to say about it
and that's what we're seeing here now i
think i am allowed to have an opinion
about the blm
organization i think i am allowed to
have an opinion about marxist
propaganda being taught in our schools i
i am going to have an opinion
about that and if goodyear doesn't like
it you know what we're going to do we're
going to boycott goodyear i think it's a
great idea
it's a great idea for for too long
republicans have allowed
uh corporate america to to push america
further to the left they've given them a
free pass
no longer my friends by the way this is
playing well for republicans this is not
playing well for democrats we'll get
into the poll numbers in just one second
first i've got to thank our friends
over at we the people holster
you know maybe you got a good handgun
but you don't have a holster well then
you're just not doing gun ownership
right we uh we want to thank you for
supporting we the people holsters
they have been flooded with orders
because record numbers of people are
buying guns and ammunition for the first
time
gee i wonder why look around your
country look at things
collapsing i wonder why people are
arming themselves if you're one of those
people please be safe please
holster that new handgun in a we the
people holster starting at just
39 we the people holsters are custom
designed to fit your firearm perfectly
they're made right here in the us of a
they have thousands of options to choose
from
plus an amazing selection of printed
holsters they're great now is the time
to support
american companies go to
wethepeopleholsters.com
knowles canon wles to get yours every
holster ships free
comes with a lifetime guarantee by the
way right now get an additional ten
dollars off with the offer code knowles
canon wles
let's bring it down to what 29 is pretty
good satisfaction guaranteed if it's not
a perfect fit send it back for a total
refund
we the people holsters dot com slash
knowles we the peopleholsters.com
knowles offer code knowles
uh joe biden's numbers are falling they
fell when uh
biden picked kamala harris as his vp
that's a bad sign you pick a vp so that
your numbers go up
same thing we don't obviously we don't
have numbers from the end of the
convention yet because the convention
just ended last night
but uh it there's no evidence yet that
biden is getting any kind of boost
like like you hope for out of a
convention that's the whole point of a
convention
uh not good news for biden i mean it's
going to be there's now going to be more
pressure for him not to debate
not to show up it just didn't work why
didn't it work
the convention was more boring than
usual these conventions are usually
pretty boring but it was more boring
than usual there weren't any kind of
spontaneous moments because
you know that's this is all pre-planned
this is basically just a zoom meeting do
you remember back in 2012
you had uh you had clint eastwood come
out for mitt romney
and he clearly didn't prepare anything
he walked on stage at the last minute
and talked to an empty chair
and it was great it was the best moment
in any political convention
certainly in my lifetime but because it
was unscripted it was
you didn't know what was going to happen
it was it was entertaining you didn't
get that
republicans need some of those moments
here luckily trump always seems to give
it to them
but you're going to need that in in the
next convention
you know that the ratings for the dnc
this year plummeted i mean they were so
so bad
trump is much better on television
obviously but the rnc
needs to keep this thing loose
entertaining bigger faster funnier
maybe get clint up there with an empty
chair certainly get trump on screen as
much as you can
i want to bring this back to what we
started with at the top of the show this
q
thing q anon which is what uh the all
that's all the democrats in the media
want to talk about
i think most conservatives don't even
know what this is they haven't even
heard of this
this is an internet meme right but the
press
they're writing about it all the time
like this is the end of the world so
what is
what is the cue thing i like president
trump also don't don't really know much
about it
but unlike democrats i i do think we
should take
the fact that this movement exists
seriously
i don't i don't think we need to worry
about anything i don't think it's the
end of the world but
the fact that there is such an internet
meme that's become
you know something of an activist
movement what does it mean
you know i take blm seriously i don't
take blm's claims
seriously but i take blm seriously and i
wonder why did this rise up so same
thing with q
the the reporter brought up three things
religion weird sex and cannibalism
right satan satanism and then
pedophilia and then cannibalism what
does that mean well
as i mentioned earlier at the was it the
2012
dnc you had
the democrats booing god you now have
blm
top leftist activists calling for
churches to be smashed
images of christ and the virgin mary to
be smashed you have
statues of saint junipero sarah being
torn down
it it seems pretty clear that there is a
religious battle going on as henry
edward cardinal manning said at bottom
all human conflict
ultimately is theological so you've got
this religious battle brewing i mean the
people leading the blm riots right the
founders of that organization
are marxists they're atheists again
and you you see this constant sort of
attack on religious americans the bitter
clingers clinging to their bibles
that image that that irritated the left
so much was trump holding up a bible
outside a church a church
that they were trying to burn down so
there's
there is clearly a religious issue going
on how about the weird sex
there's plenty of weird sex going on
obviously there's the jeffrey epstein
thing that seems to involve every
prominent leftist in america
but even you know there's a show now on
netflix
it's called cuties my wife showed me
this last night she showed me the
trailer for it
it's called it's about 11 year old
like go-go dancers or something this
listen to this description
this is just a from the netflix website
cuties amy age 11
becomes fascinated with a twerking dance
crew
hoping to join them she starts to
explore her femininity
defying her family's traditions
that is like pedophile catnip how on
earth
what sicko executive at netflix allowed
this thing to go up
like i i know you know sometimes we hear
all these
crazy people on the internet they talk
about how there's pedophilia going on
all over the place
well how do you explain that that's
pretty weird isn't it there's like a
show about 11 year olds twerking
and exploring their femininity against
their family's wishes
that's that's weird like you know
jeffrey epstein flying around on an
airplane with
prince andrew and all these top mostly
left-wing politicians
he was a member of mar-a-lago so there
were photos of him with trump too but
bill clinton apparently flew on his
plane like 27 times
that's weird isn't that weird that's a
little weird isn't it so clearly there's
some weird sex thing going on and by the
way the only thing anyone talks about
these days is sex that's why lgbtq can
you know
goes now 26 alphabet letters long
these people beyond this question of
pedophilia people are just obsessed with
sex they're talking about sex
all the time so there's there's that
aspect going on and then cannibalism
there are some real cannibals like rizza
aslan formerly of cnn
who ate human brains on television
actually did that and that weird that's
a little weird too
uh but there's this issue of cannibalism
at a cultural level which
which i think is actually what's going
on here we are eating ourselves alive
we are we are devouring our own culture
right cannibalism has a has a kind of
metaphorical meaning as well
people are just devouring themselves
because they've they've run out of other
things to consume
what is i mean obviously we see that now
we're tearing down our own history we're
tearing down our own art we're covering
up our own art
where we're destroying our own politics
destroying our own institutions frankly
riza aslan aside there's much more
evidence of a cultural cannibalism a
civilizational cannibalism
than of a personal cannibalism those
things are all real
okay and the media right now are asking
about the q anon
thing they're asking about a bunch of
internet memes they should be asking
themselves
about what the phenomenon means the fact
that people are
worried about satanism and pedophilia
and
cannibalism why what does that tell you
about your culture
if these mainstream media journalists
had two brain cells to rub together
they would be able to see some some real
insight in
in the very fact of these phenomenons
just like i encouraged the left
consider the fact of blm why has this
thing risen up
so too i would encourage the left
consider why
these things that you you're so obsessed
with consider why
they've risen up but that would require
introspection and of course they're not
capable of that
um by the way there's one thing i know
i'm running late on the mailbag but i
don't care i've got to i've got to
mention my friend amanda milius
a great great young filmmaker you might
have heard the name milius because
her her father is one of the most
legendary filmmakers in hollywood john
millius wrote apocalypse now
did the dirty hairy movies coney and the
barbarian red dawn all these great
great great guy and and she's a terrific
young filmmaker
she's got a movie she's been working on
secretly called plot against the
president
this this is coming out now it's coming
out very not
not right now but it's coming out very
soon it details
the russia hoax the attempted coup
d'etat to overthrow a duly elected
president take a look at just a little
bit of the trailer
i recently confirmed that on numerous
occasions the intelligence community
incidentally collected information about
u.s citizens involved in the trump
transition
it was shocking to see some of the
overclassification that was done to hide
either corruption or abuse of authority
and just to make sure certain agencies
didn't look bad
we have a peaceful transition of power
process
that's not what happened there were more
meetings there were more leaks there
were
more attacks the thing that they were
investigating the trump campaign
for is what they themselves were doing
not just the democratic party and their
operatives but also the fbi
i were writing about the time frame that
we lived in and that we're living in now
i would say it wasn't
supposed to happen they weren't supposed
to know the entire time this was going
on they thought this was going to be
what sunk the donald trump presidency
and they were just
looking for the golden goose and they
still haven't found it because it
doesn't exist
this movie is going to be great it's
going to be explosive go check it out
the plot against the president you know
subscribe wherever so that you can get
notifications when it comes out
uh thank you for subscribing to my
youtube channel appreciate it we've uh
you know got some great stuff coming out
this weekend so be sure to uh
head over there we've got a backstage
coming up tomorrow 4 p.m
uh pacific time 7 p.m eastern time
join all access you need to get it right
now obviously you get to do all access
live you get all this very
very fun stuff we're gonna have one for
the dnc we're gonna have one for the rnc
so head on over there right now go to
dailywire.com
dailywire.com use uh promo code
dailywrite.com promo code access you'll
get 20 off all access and two leftist
years tumblers dailywire.com
knowles promo code access we'll be right
back with the mailbag
there's too much good stuff to talk
about today but we got to get to the
mailbag i will speed through we will get
through as many questions as possible
from alejandro dear future vice
president michael knowles if you were
selected to be the republican vice
president for the 2020 election
what would your opening statement be at
the vice presidential debate
i would get up there and i would say uh
thank you so much uh it's such an honor
to be here i would especially like to
thank
the democratic party for not reading the
constitution because you don't realize
that right now i am still just a little
bit too young to be vice president
uh but since the democrats don't read
the constitution that's perfectly well
and good
let's get to the questions that would be
my opening statement you know it's
unfortunate the democrats don't know
anything about the constitution
but there can be a little silver lining
in that storm cloud we can we can use it
to turn lemons into lemonade and part of
that would be
would be my selection as vice president
it's great i'll take it even before the
age of 35
from catalina what a great name catalina
it's a
nice island off the coast of california
hi michael skinny boy and master of kofi
i'm a rising high school senior
my college search came to a grinding
halt recently when i fully realized that
the environment at the ivy league
schools is overwhelmingly liberal
i was really interested in applying to
princeton dartmouth and harvard but
after seeing so much leftism at the
admissions
sessions and in their promotions i'm
reconsidering like you i'm catholic and
conservative
what was your experience in the
political environment political
environment of yale
what should i do i don't want to be
universally hated on my college campus
for being conservative thanks so much
i love the show listen in every day god
bless depends what you what you want
you know there are some colleges where
you can get a magnificent
classical education liberal education
even
thomas aquinas college franciscan of
steubenville hillsdale
you know very famously offers a more
classical and rigorous education
but if you want a big brand name school
you know let's say you want to go work
in
banking or consulting or you know get
into a really top law school or
something like that
if you do want to kind of go down that
route which
which has uh increasingly diminishing
returns
because uh now people are beginning to
realize that the yale of
2020 is not the yale of 1920. and
frankly it's not even the yell of 10
years ago
um so but if you want to do that yale
has a pretty robust
area for conservatives they've got the
william f buckley jr program they've got
the tory party which is a
great organization at yale uh they do
they do have a number of conservatives
that have come through there
the campus has gotten very left-wing
even since i was there and even when i
was there
you know i got along just fine had a
great time you know but but whenever
a political activity that i was working
on got a little too hot
i was absolutely persona non grata on
campus for at least a month or two
and then people would kind of forget you
know and i'd get to go back to parties
and things again and it was all fine
until
but if if you do things that are
effective in politics then you're
gonna have a lot of people dislike you
for that and that's just uh that's just
the cost of
doing business that's the cost of doing
politics rather you've really got to ask
yourself what do i want
if you want a kind of classical
education that's
that's not uh you know going to have all
the trappings of
of maybe an ivy league school then i
would say go to one of those other
colleges
if you want to get that big brand name
just know
you're going to be in a decidedly
leftist institution
for a long time and uh and you're gonna
have to make your way sometimes that'll
be easy sometimes that'll be hard but
conservative insight is nothing in life
is free from anonymous
i'm michael i'm going to be married 10
years this october together for 12 and
my wife and i have a three-year-old son
earlier this year i found out she
accumulated over 40 grand of credit card
debt and we had to refinance the house
to pay it off
further she recently became pregnant and
besides me begging and pleading she went
ahead
to planned parenthood and took an
abortion pill oh my gosh
she's also been nasty to me and has said
i'm needy and is threatening to leave me
when i've been victim here
i want to stay together for our son and
to work through the issues we've had
we've had many good years together i'm
simply at a loss at what to do here i
don't want to give up
on my son and family but i've been hurt
wronged and i've been blamed for the
marriage failing
she claims i'm controlling and wants to
leave as i'm holding her back from
achieving her career dreams i would
appreciate your thoughts
yeah you need to get your wife in line
i'm very sorry that you've gone through
this i mean
obviously the things you've described
are
horrific um you you need to get your
wife in line
uh you know you've gotta you've gotta
lead the family i know that i know that
modern feminism and all this stuff
might make this confusing but uh
the the the idea that your wife could
even get the thought of i've gotta i've
got to leave my family because
you're holding me back from whatever
making widgets at the widget factory
is is preposterous in itself and uh
i i don't know either you've got to be
persuasive you know and and
show her why that's so wrong i would
certainly go into marriage counseling i
mean that
you know she killed your child you know
i mean that that is a
it's it's unthinkable it's unthinkable
that that sort of thing would happen
so you you need to put measures in place
to make sure that doesn't
that that can't happen again you you
know i'll
taking that example aside i mean that's
just so horrific let's just use the
credit card example
how did she run up 40 grand in credit
card debt without you knowing
you should be seeing these financial
statements you if
if she has a separate credit card that's
obviously a bad idea
for someone who's going to run up 40
grand in credit card debt she should not
be permitted to have a separate credit
card
you your f your one flesh your finances
should be the same
anyway so i would take control i would
just take control of the situation
ironically what seems to what what she
seems to think as as you write in in
your note is
that you know you're you're too
controlling but i i would imagine
if you are not even looking at your
credit card statements you're not
controlling enough not nearly
controlling enough
uh and and i would uh i don't know the
problem would appear to be
this kind of modern idea of
feminism or how that relates to marriage
i think you've got to get a little bit
more
old school here and traditional probably
the first step would be would be
marriage therapy and i would just make
sure
that you go to a marriage therapist who
isn't some lunatic
feminist you pick it you call the shots
you're the head of the household
uh and uh if if she leaves you i hope
she doesn't
uh that's on her
you and and uh you you know divorce is a
horrible horrible thing for a child so i
would not
i don't think you should leave um but
you need to lead your family you can't
you can't let her
do these sorts of horrible things and
you need to also acknowledge anything
maybe that you have done that has led to
this
you know obviously you generally
speaking it takes two to tango so
marriage therapy would be the place to
start but but you need to lead you need
to take charge and and i
i don't think if if your situation gets
worse
i don't think it's going to get worse
because you took too much control you
took too much of the lead
i think it will get worse because you've
taken a back seat and
you've allowed her to to uh to take the
lead too much
without knowing more details that's
that's about the best i can give you but
uh very very terrible situation sorry to
hear that you're in it
from aaron one question i've always
struggled with is romans chapter
13 and the submission to the governing
authorities as a conservative i've
always struggled with being submissive
to the governing authorities
mainly when thinking about the
revolutionary war i want to believe in a
good argument for the colonies rebelling
against the crown but i do not believe
that the catholic or other confessional
churches
would have supported the overthrowing of
that authority historically speaking
can a conservative have been a supporter
of the american revolution
and how thanks this question comes up
from time to time
even beyond uh just the catholic
question even some conservative
protestants say i don't i wouldn't
support the american revolution
uh saint thomas aquinas is pretty clear
that there is a
there is a right of revolution in very
limited circumstances
so the question is does uh does the
american revolution meet those
circumstances there's also a question of
the nature of the american revolution
the american revolution didn't overthrow
the king of england right it didn't it
didn't oppose
king george it separated the united
states from great britain
it in the revolutionaries words it
acknowledged that there was this
separation that these
political bonds had been dissolved and
now you've got this separate country
that already had its own governing
institutions
that already had its own culture for at
that point over a century
a century and a half or so i i think
there is a conservative and christian
case for the american revolution
i i don't care particularly to come down
decisively on that issue i think there's
a good argument
also that the revolution was not
justified you you
i've heard both of those arguments
that's fine i think the more pertinent
question though is
today what is your view of the american
revolution where no one's going to get
in a time machine and go back
to 1776. so how do you look at it now
and i think it's
very clear that uh in our
in our due submission to the the civil
authority uh we
certainly should respect the regime that
was established in 1776
and that has been a generally speaking a
wonderful
political event in the history of the
world so i would
i would even kind of remove yourself
from the historical question though it's
fun to kick it around i think there is
an argument for it
and just think about the present
political question
all right i wish we could get to more
but typically i ran late so we'll just
have to wait until next week or maybe
we'll be able to chat on all access
or maybe we'll be able to chat on
backstage we got all that coming up
tomorrow in the meantime i'm michael
knowles this is the michael knowles show
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies
executive producer jeremy boary
supervising producers
mathis glover and robert sterling
technical producer austin stevens
assistant director pavel wadowski editor
and associate producer
danny d'amico audio mixer robin
fenderson
hair and makeup nika geneva production
assistant
ryan love the michael knowles show is a
daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 20. hey
everybody it's andrew clavin host of the
andrew clavin show
you know some people are depressed
because the american republic is
collapsing the
end of days is approaching and the moon
has turned to blood but on the andrew
clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way
through the apocalypse with me andrew
[Music]
clayton